I've said this quote before because I
love it so very much and because it's
really kind of the envelope of all that
per Max and also this course in
particular right so can't gas before I
just like the picture
and probably because it employs you know
what are you looking at you just you're
looking at the spectrum of light right
this is like this is a prism over here
and there's just normal you know
something I would ever come through and
then out comes it still just try and
rewind it back to the days before we do
the order like I'm looking at right now
is made out of a spectrum right this is
not known for centuries right in fact
Isaac Newton is very famous this is kind
of creepy story before you're basically
vision I apologize in advance but it is
true so I'm just gonna tell you anyway
Isaac he was trying to work out like the
nature of white right and particularly
the nature of color and so you've got
two example color color is received in
the eyes so maybe color is something
generated by our lives right so you took
a scalpel and he inserted it as far as
you possibly could into his own eye and
he saw some weird things unsurprisingly
saw some red from which he concluded
well yes color is part of the optic like
it's generated by your brain by your
eyes right thankfully you didn't go much
better
okay hey you can see we've come a long
way since then right but this is an
eminently simple thing I'm the youngest
child knows what light is followed by
all there are so many depths to
understand so he comes the story that
was just the warm-up this story in my
the title this story is from the student
the fish and I believe that's pronounced
the gas emits aren't pretty not quite
beyond that because
it stands for I this story was on
recounted by this guy I'm Samuel Scott
you can oh you can find the text for
this story and I highly encourage you to
actually read the story for yourself
because I'm just gonna keep you like the
super super super down it's papads okay
this story is about a student you're
studying fish and guessing you can
always show you know I guess he was a
Tomlin Lewis I guess he was a scholar of
marine life okay you can kind of see you
swim like what does it look like he's
drawing what can you see once you
recognize that's a that's a starfish
what's that kind of is jellyfish right
what what might that be
it's like an ax DVD or something like
that so what you've got is these various
diagrams and he was drawing her no I
guess it was this super important
professor okay and any student who
wanted to know anything about marine
life came to you and so this is this
more but he comes to me and he's like
I'm so excited who's about to meet this
you know famous resident there's so much
stuff he's like very influential in the
field and it's so excited to be able to
sit underneath human and basket is
visited okay and I guess it says all
your Linde student okay that means you
need one of these he gets a fish gets a
fish and sets it down in front of the
student record says I would like you to
study this fish and I'll come back soon
and I'll come and talk to you right at
first you know this too is been
frustrated because like I I am a student
of fish I've worked my way all the way
up to being under this great professor
right and he's not saying you need to me
you just even be a fish I the fish right
but he's just posted fine okay he's
gonna come back so he starts to study he
starts to notice things about it for
instance I mean you're looking at a fish
what what kinds of things do you notice
about this fish just shuts on that
really obvious it's scary
right it's
you can touch it this is kind of a snow
your hair or anything like that what
else do you know there's a fin right
actually this is miss Biddy Fitz you can
count them up you come over that
position right the feeds are all the
same as each other at different kinds of
shapes all right what else do you do
that's it
there's a line it puts it what's that
about right look you can see the scales
he has scales he but okay then we can
get on another note right so the
students sitting there and how was Haas
and I guess he's nowhere to be seen
Hey and then I guess he comes back he
says so what did you notice about the
fish
just like you okay cool
keep going I'll be back what's he do
before he's before you can say anything
I guess it's already gone it's a
competition for hours looking at this
one fish like I want to learn about
other things don't you tell me something
when I would superb the out insights and
I just stuck with this statement how is
possible and it gets the end of his
first day and I guess he comes back and
he's like so sick of this [ __ ] right I
in the story it says this fish became a
loner listen to me right but he's
noticing people things like okay there's
like you know this is a did here this is
all these things and I guess he's very
upset he's very upset the end of the
first thing he says this dude he says
after all these hours with Univision to
the student you've not looked very
carefully why you haven't seen one of
the most conspicuous features of the
animal which is as plainly before you
as the fish itself look again look I can
after however many hours of staring at
that fish now what happens as the story
continues and ends the student spends
days and days and days with just one
solitary fish and sure enough by looking
and they're looking again and thinking
deeply about this very obvious object
sure enough McCain's war and bought
insights and finally you know I guess
she's happy after like a week okay great
you're ready to move on to the next
station and then and so the whole point
though is that with a very simple object
right we can train ourselves to look see
few things and then just be contended
move forward okay if we contend to do
that in any field but especially in
mathematics okay understand your face
will never develop ok now I've said
before you know the way in the
mathematics kind of course is you do
this a little bit you like rushing
through topics and all that right we are
not doing that here have the luxury of
time and you can think about something
which you think you'd order like a
simple fish and you can push on it